m
[Musique]
comme tous les ans ils sont arrivés mais
ils sont pressés
[Musique]
temps moyen de séjour à paris pour un
touriste étranger deux jours et demi
dans ces conditions pas une minute à
perdre pas question de flâner à la
découverte de la ville et pourtant le
touriste veut tout voir tout savoir
alors pour faire face à cette urgence
deux conditions indispensables
motorisation et organisations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
messieurs du breuil l'entreprise que
vous dirigez fait du sahel singh comment
peut-on traduire cela en français
d'après sa souveraine l'organisation de
visites de ville et excursions dans les
environs des grands centres touristiques
que ce soit paris londres new york
berlin
toutes les grandes villes du monde ont
une entreprise comme la nôtre qui fait
du entre guillemets sightseeing
à vous qui venait parfois de l'autre
bout de la planète pour découvrir ou
pour revoir la grandville que non selon
le passionné par l'innovation cnra
monaco nancy matos à la syrie ni quand
ni la lettre à l'immense talent des
doublements matin son inimitié aux
mamans l'autorité note de stratégie du
ni sexe âge et attentif comme des
courriers
il est cool et il regarde la leçon
d'aujourd'hui essayant de retenir un nom
et de découvrir une image entre deux
autocars
d'autres touristes ont le même souci de
napoléon à richelieu et de la concorde à
saint germain des prés il doit se
dérouler sous leurs yeux des monuments
des palais des quartiers mais ne
cherchez ni l'heure ni la continuité
historique
un seul impératif respecter les temps on
leur avait dit il y a encore des
amoureux mais ces deux là ne sont ici
que pour les besoins du cinéma
alors paris en trois heures
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une gageure départ nous l'avons
préparé en trois heures en fait nous
nous montrons nous montrons ce que tous
les étrangers s'attendent à voir
c'est à dire nous devons leur montrer en
trois heures les les grandes images de
paris celles qui sont connues depuis des
générations
à la fois ingénieur du son guide et
hôtesses florence veille sur ses
touristes
c'est un bon moyen d'orientation du
moins on voit tout ce qui est important
à paris très superficiellement mais
cela permet ensuite d'y retourner de
retourner aux endroits par les ir
ensuite après le tour ça permet de
choisir et ça c'est l'intérêt du side
singh en fait mais pour un parisien qui
voit passer c'est qu'a remplie de
touristes étrangers bardet l'appareil
photo tous s'apprêtent à paris ah oui
s'apprêtent même beaucoup à rire c'est
toujours la réaction des gens dans qui
voit un quart double passer en quarts à
étages il a réuni se moquent les jambes
mais en fait dans une ville étrangère
certainement il fera la même chose
doublé vous de montréal au québec
vous avez choisi ce moyen de visiter
paris en trois heures c'est pas qu'on
fait quand on voit qu ils tous en
général que l'intéressé jeu apporte pas
mal de connaissances sur l'histoire
tous les français c'est bien connu dans
le monde entier porte un béret basque et
19 ans n'est pas venu en france
pensez-vous dont trois heures office
carlton non c'est impossible c'est
impossible quand tout le pari il
faudrait des jours les semaines pour
voir tout paris non vraiment les jours
son sens hier une pense pas tu peux voir
paris en trois heures je crois que c'est
une bonne formule en ce sens qu'on peut
tout voir dans les mêmes journées sont
trop trop de difficultés et pour vous
madame découverte
ah oui depuis ce qu'on avait rêvé
puisqu'on a vu enfin au terme du voyage
laventure pour les plus courageux vingt
minutes pas une de plus pour découvrir
la place du tertre
[Musique]
et pour le touriste studieux ayant
encore les cours du soir
paris la nuit un son et lumière
motorisée de la concorde à la bastille
l'écran autocar promènent leurs charges
de touristes soigneusement protégé
contre le monde extérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et puis bien sûr une spécialité qui se
veut fidèle à sa légende
paris by night ça existe encore oui
celle à venir d'ailleurs toute façon ça
va venir maintenant le mieux pour les
touristes pour les touristes oui il pour
les français pour recevoir bien les
touristes
vous pensez que ici happy girls enfants
quand tout ce qu'il faut pour qu'il soit
durable bien évidemment biscaye en fait
tout ce qu'il faut ils sont contents ah
ils partent tous contents il mesure tout
cela mais j'ai pas besoin de vous cacher
bon alors elles sont c'est que c'est
donc sur la preuve c'est qu'on les
reçoit bien alors le guitariste jazz
live et regroupe tout ce qu'ils
souhaitaient tout ce qu'ils souhaitaient
surtout ceux qui ont connu la france il
ya une vingtaine d'années ils reviennent
tous contents et qui cherchent tous deux
le jet d'eau
de pigalle aux champs elysées tout un
spectacle le zoom affectif quand on a
rêvé dans le monde entier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois heures pour paris c'est peut-être
un peu long alors le touriste pressé
dispose d'un autre moyen plus rapide
[Musique]
monsieur bruel paris une heure quinze
ans m qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quelle tristesse 1h15
2000 ans d'histoire 10 millions de
parisiens il faudrait connaître
personnellement remarquer que c'est
presque 10 millions de bureaux
maintenant alors est ce qu'on connaît
des bureaux ne sais plus de toute façon
moi je suis ma fureur la fureur parce
que à bateaux scellant un bateau ça doit
être lent à bateaux ça doit s'accorder à
un certain rythme au calme et comment
empêcher
comment inciter le touriste à être un
animal calme et non pas un pousseur
furieux qui sait au rugby et de paysages
en paysage sans rien voir et surtout
sans rien sentir ce très important quand
même lorsqu'on croit à l'importance
d'affectivité de voir comment tous ces
citoyens en quelques heures sont
ailleurs sont déjà ailleurs
en somme si je comprends bien le bateau
c'est un entracte entre deux avions bien
sûr c'est un entracte entre deux avions
j'ai fait j'ai reconstruit récemment un
bateau que j'appelle le job götze pour
des jumbo
c'est à dire les avions 747 qui débarque
450 personnes qui viennent ensemble
boulotter je ne sais quoi
sur un des bateaux 1 et puis ils
repartent le lendemain pour aller à
florence enfin les hauts lieux le
circuit des hauts-lieux l'espèce de
accélération permanente
c'est affligeant tout c'est inquiétant
parce que qu'est-ce qui restera
[Musique]
vous êtes à paris tous les points
ensemble
d'où venez vous vitaux d'israël cambodge
pour combien de temps êtes-vous à paris
le temps quand on a l'argent et que
pensez-vous du tourisme traditionnel qui
voit paris en trois heures dans un
autocar son fameux sortir est intacte
non j'aime pas c'est pareil carte
postale
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le
tourisme que vous pratiquez parler avec
les gens vivre comme les français me
fais le président paris en trois heures
paris en 1h15 dérision nécessité au jour
à répond tout de suite nécessité e pour
les touristes étrangers qui viennent en
france il est et notamment à paris
d'être impossible d'envisager de faire
vue de la réception de l'accueil sans
leur proposer des visites de notre belle
ville les excursions que nous offrons
vieilli et peut-être aussi ne répondent
plus à l'esprit moderne du touriste il
faudrait que nos collègues organisateurs
soit un peu imaginatif et une heure et
demie de visite de paris s'est
réellement trop peu il faudrait trouver
une autre formule pour qu' il puisse
voir plus de choses qu'ils ne voient pas
dans les excursions classique
si vous aviez sa visite est une grande
ville étrangère est-ce que vous
choisirez ce moyen
oui c'est le meilleur moyen de de vue de
voir une ville ensuite on peut retourner
aux endroits qu'ils intérêt sur puce
mais le moyen est bon je trouve c'est un
parfait bien sûr c'est superficiel mais
ça donne une très bonne idée
alors paris en trois heures mais en ce
moment pourrait france et à l'étranger
combien de temps pour rome athènes
madrid ou new york
[Musique]